[Musique]
c'est la plus haute tour inclinée du
monde c'est du stade olympique de
montréal dont la construction a pris fin
en 1987
onze ans après les jeux notre visite
débute au pied de la structure fermée
aux touristes depuis un an et si va
avoir une billetterie a bien pris racine
biétry et de l'autre côté les travaux de
démolition se sont déroulées au cours de
la dernière année le parc olympique a
projeté de la pandémie pour faire
avancer un projet de longue date
rénover le funiculaire le hâle
touristiques ainsi que les espaces
corporatifs et l'observatoire qui se
trouve au sommet le funiculaire lui
fonctionne toujours mais il est en fin
de vie en presque 35 ans il a fait
environ 600 milles aller retour entre le
hall d'accueil et l'observatoire la
machinerie est fatiguée elle sera
changée elle aussi la montée dure deux
minutes le temps d'apprécier la vue sur
l'est de montréal
arrivées au sommet force est d'admettre
que l'observatoire est un peu décevant
le panorama est obstrué la situation
sera corrigée
si on s'approche mais on constate que ça
donne sur la toiture du stade et ça nous
permet d'avoir jusqu'à ras bord on va
complètement détruit les trois blancs
qu'on voit ici et on va remplacer sa
part un plancher des planchers var mais
rien ne vaudra la vue que les touristes
auront à partir du toit de la tour du
stade
cet espace sera enfin ouvert au public
on pourra aussi présenter des spectacles
c'est la plus haute origines et au monde
donc à 165 m et c'est cet effet
d'inclinaison les deux vertige qu'on
veut faire sentir aux visiteurs une fois
qu'on est rendu observateurs y aura des
planchers de voir que les gens pourront
aller dessus ou pas et
da voire même des plans inclinés à
nouveau de l'observatoire qui vont
permettre aux gens de se pencher
il s'inclinait au dessus du vide en
travers devant et il y aura même à
l'avant ici pour compléter une espèce de
plancher en porte-à-faux kirop vers le
centre-ville d'après m 2 qui permettra
aux gens d'être carrément dans le vide
plancher de verre murs de verre le parc
olympique songe même à aménager une
passerelle suspendue
un peu comme celle de la tour du cn et
l'autorité des marchés publics lui a
interdit de confier le contrat de gré à
gré à la firme qui a conçu et construit
la passerelle de toronto cela étant dit
québec et en faveur du projet de
rénovation des espaces touristiques de
la tour dont les coûts sont estimés à 55
millions de dollars en 2026 2027 ont
brisé un achalandage ayant qui va
avoisiner les 400 mille visiteurs par
année le tour du stade demeure l'un des
emblèmes de montréal
mais ce n'est pas demain la veille
qu'elle sera ouverte aux touristes
malgré le déconfinement le site restera
fermée pendant toute la durée des
travaux qui devraient être complétés en
2023 ou en 2024 ici jérôme l'abbé radio
canada mon frère
[Musique]